so my rule for myself in this particular
presentation was that I was not allowed
to talk about anything from my thesis
which means that we're going to have
this really nice opportunity to actually
consider where this is going
what's the broader picture of where
human-computer interaction can think
about work at large scale and then when
I tell people that I do social and crowd
computing
most people immediately jump to this as
a model of what I do where either what
we've basically got is a simple like
button or or an articulated social
network and we're just putting that on
top of how people interact or we're
paying people a cent or two in order to
do some work and what I hope to get
across to you today are ways in which we
can push far far beyond those kinds of
models and start thinking about what
happens when we talk about designing at
large scale for emergence for tens
hundreds thousands millions of
individuals all coming together trying
to do things and as something that's
moving beyond the the narrow picture
that we've been talking about before I'm
actually going to speak broadly about
three topics I want to talk about where
I think crowdsourcing can go if we push
it that way I'd like to talk also about
social computing and the kind of role
that it has in design for interactive
systems and designing for social
interaction more broadly and then
starting to push forward in some work
that's really just starting in in the
last year or two about what happens when
we consider crowds of people out on the
web as a data source that we can then
pull back together and use to rethink
the kinds of interactive systems you and
I use today
so with that agenda in mind I'm going to
start with the crowd and this is a piece
called the future of crowd work which
actually just appeared at CSC W last
week so if you were there this will look
very familiar but I'd like to sort of
use this as an opportunity to sketch out
what I see is some really in
interesting questions as we think about
where crowdsourcing research needs to go
so before we start there let's rewind
early crowdsourcing research so I think
the model that is probably most popular
or familiar if you're thinking about
crowdsourcing is something like this we
have two distributed workers who are
going to consider something
independently past their work off to
some third arbiter who's going to look
at this work and adjudicate any
decisions and for me something that's
actually a pretty good encapsulation of
this would be Greg riddles thesis work
where he introduced some of this these
notions of algorithms where he actually
got crowds to decipher this text I
certainly can't do it but it turns out
that by following this exact process you
can and looping it you can actually get
all but I think one or two words
correctly transcribed this is actually
feedback on an essay if you can't tell
so this happened about four years ago
but when I when I talk about early
crowdsourcing research this is this is
near history in fact this model and the
bullet point there's more back to 1760
and here I'm going to talk about some
work here that david alan grier wrote in
a book called when computers were human
this this man Neil Maskell masculine was
the British Royal astronomer and he was
charged with creating the first British
nautical Almanac which is to say you'd
be out at sea and your little lost you
want to be able to look at stars do some
calculations and figure out where you
are and what did he do in order to
accomplish this he actually used the
postal service on the left you here you
can see instructions that he mailed out
and on the rent was a big spreadsheet
that people would fill out this in a
distributed fashion into it and then
they would collect it passage to that
third verifier and they would use this
to actually generate these charts that
people use to navigate at sea so really
we're talking something many many years
ago especially far beyond the computer
age but there are some really
interesting parallels one individual in
particular who had some some relevance
to
early crowdsourcing work is this
gentleman they wonder who this is by
sight sorry no no this is only the first
people involved in this creation of the
nautical almanac sendin of some repute
who you might know his name is Charles
Babbage he was one of the first
individuals who actually helped create
this particular this Almanac and managed
it Vantage of course being the person
who created the difference engine the
analytical engine the precursors of
modern computing and he in fact had had
several insights in this area that we
still sort of try to reflect on today I
wish more people would take advantage of
this he noticed that two people doing
the same thing in the same way make
correlated errors so the next time that
you have ten people on Mechanical Turk
all do the same task and end up with the
same kinds of blind spots
Babbage figured this out and we as a
crowdsourcing field still haven't
haven't managed this fast-forwarding I
would say that the height of the
original crowdsourcing work was was in
the WPA in the 1930s so this was a
project that actually created
mathematical tables just like with the
with the nautical chart this was mainly
aimed at ballistics so a war usage
eventually in the 1940s and it's how you
had four hundred and fifty people in
this gigantic room where they none of
them were actually or very few of them
were actually math experts they
distributed this process of doing these
calculations and and the intelligence
was built into the process in a in a
type of in a sort of distributed
cognition sense that they were able to
create these these emergent behaviors
and they at the height had 450 people
they called them human computers because
they were computing these mathematical
functions turns out another another
interesting thing here this is the
origin of the term computer people were
human come
Peter's eventually via the computer we
know and love today came around and
replaced these individuals so they went
down the computer that the computer
science that we have now begun and it's
only more recently recent history that
we've started to see the crowdsourcing
research that you may be familiar with
we start we started seeing people start
to create a with algorithms thinking
about what happens if you can program
with individuals playing the part of
some rules some excuse me some elements
of that program thinking about
incentives how do we get people to to
act in the way that we would want how do
we actually create systems that embed
crowd intelligence this is the work I've
been spending a lot of time thinking
about thinking about how algorithms can
actually become smart computational
managers trying to make sure that people
aren't wasting their time and thinking
more broadly about how we can take
simpler work and compose it into really
complex tasks like here cloud forge
tried to write simple Wikipedia pages so
that brings us to today and what we want
to ask is what is the future of crowd
work and I think that there's one
question that we've used as a useful as
a useful instrument to try and ground
this question because may often when I
talk to people about this the response
is oh yeah we should make it cheaper
more optimized higher quality let's say
okay so what would it take if you have
if you were to have a kid right now or
you were to have one soon or you have
grandkids between where we are now such
that you would be proud of that kid if
they decided to full-time enter the
crowd workforce I would hazard a guess
that if your if your kid came to you
today and said I want to spend all my
time on Amazon Mechanical Turk you're
not going to be super happy with them
but I think we can get to this kind of a
situation and I asked this not not as
something that's unanswerable that is
something that tries to anchor the kinds
of contributions we can make and this
isn't something that I asked by myself
in fact this particular work was a
collaboration I think I was the only
computer scientist
in the group between cognitive science
management design sociology economics
there's a lot of really interacting
forces here when we think about what we
call crowd work and really what I want
to try that at one level get across is a
move from just paid micro tasking
there's notion of what crowd work might
look like and I'm gonna broaden this
this definition just to say any task
that's completed online by a distributed
elastic workforce in exchange for pay
and a lot of things can be covered by
this and in fact blinders argued that
about 20 percent of our current American
jobs could be sent down a wire these are
things like programming accounting
marketing even machine operators think
of say like UAVs and in particular
recent evidence for crowd work
fitting some models for this suggest
that volume is going to end up being
about four hundred and fifty four
billion dollars a year that's about 91
billion dollars hour hours per year
employing about forty five million
full-time workers that's a lot yeah yes
so what I'm saying the pool of people
who you're considering is in a sense
distributed inelastic yes
so here o desk has many many individuals
who could do this work they're applying
your choosing some number of them so
yeah I say nothing about this needing to
be tightly decomposed tasks which i
think is actually important like we're
not we're not talking here about
something that can be done in five
seconds five minutes it might take a
week I think there is some sense in
which crowdsourcing will continue to
think about ways in which traditionally
monolithic work can be distributed but I
don't think we have to talk about it
with respect to you know being an
employee at a company for twenty years
for example
yes so I mean in a sense it seems like a
natural progression from like breathing
its work to make sure it says micro
freelancing innocent listen that's sort
of where the what I would suggest is you
you you will probably start to see the
an increase in the number of individuals
who spend all of their time effectively
as full-time contractors I think in an
ideal world you know you have the
ability for people who want to to be
able to run their own contract work as
much as they want or if you're a
stay-at-home dad you can put in a few
hours while the baby is asleep hopefully
they'll just giving you more flexibility
sorry mr. Watkins growth is the one out
of one hand in a sense it's a crowd yes
I mean it's not online which is sort of
the although Craigslist is I suppose I
mean I think we're not I'm not trying to
reframe existing practice I'm in a sense
what I'm trying to say is that it's
actually already happening I'm just
trying to put a lens onto it so yes I
think what's actually new or interesting
to me is not necessarily just that it's
it doesn't need to be distributed into
tiny pieces but that technology is
mediating the entire process from
everything from the the hiring to the
formation of the team to how the work is
done which is what we've so far thought
about about how to distribute it into
small pieces I think we have the ability
as this moves forward to think about a
much broader picture of what that might
mean
we've come back to this I yeah I'm very
happy to be wrong
rivers what you're saying is obviously
true the question is trying to research
on it is that too broad and do you want
to focus in on narrow pieces that this
is what so I'm going to zoom back in in
just a moment to I think the kinds of
problems that I think are solvable when
you take this kind of a lens so just to
be clear of what I'm comparing this to I
think you know the current frame is
something that looks a lot more like
this Amazon Mechanical Turk that's
framed a lot of our discussions around
crowdsourcing and transforming that a
little bit into the model that you sort
of see you have small simple tasks that
are independent workers are
undifferentiated they're pseudonymous
work is automatically aggregated you
know these are things like image
labeling speech tagging those kinds of
things and I would be far from the first
person to suggest that that can lead to
negative outcomes you know there's
there's a risk of falling into this
framing permanently six Silverman has
talked about this little irani Ben
Peterson you know and if you think about
this requesters are going to view
workers as exchangeable untrustworthy
sugars and and the workers are going to
view these requesters as distant
capricious having lots of power over
over your ability to do anything so in a
sense what I'm trying to push back
against is not necessarily the notion
that things can be distributed into
small parts but that the notion that
doing so needs can only be done in the
particular way that we've done it so far
because looking forward you know the
kind of work that we do is complex its
creative its interdependence you know
you think about things like writing a
news story writing software or even say
like asking could a crowd compose a
symphony another kind of interesting
question because if you tried to do that
right now
it would really not work if everyone's
generating their own stanza and you're
trying to reassemble them that might not
be the thing you would try but it is the
the way the model would map on to it so
you just
about a few of the kinds of issues you
would find you know there's
interdependencies between movements you
need to have expertise people are going
to drop out of any online system so what
can we do about this so this is one
place where we're starting to see why
it's actually useful to have an
interdisciplinary perspective here in
fact the group of us that we're
discussing it decided to draw on two
different perspectives together one one
of those being distributed organizations
in the management literature as well as
notions from say distributed computing
here in computer science and it is that
a lot of the challenges they face
actually synthesize quite well I think
if you think of it in the following way
so the first thing you have to do is
often decompose a task so if you're
planning a conference you need to split
you know say finding a venue from
reviewing papers but if you're doing you
need to actually split up crawling the
web and likewise you need to put
together a team so again if you're if
you're a conference chair you need to
find respectable academics or coerce
civil friends to help take on onwards
and if you're Google you have people
taking on different roles as well so say
a master node in a prostitue MapReduce
process coordinating other computers and
then we have workflows that need to
happen so finally again we have you know
potentially multistage review processes
in these conferences and in computing we
call these algorithms things that
actually will often pipeline work
between different stages and each of
these really has things that can happen
with crowd work there are a lot of
different challenges that we need to
solve I'm not going to talk about all of
these in fact I'm actually just going to
focus broadly on three categories of
what we can think about in terms of
opportunities for research which crowd
workers with the crowd work itself and
what the where the computation has to
play I'm going to just focus on one or
two of them and this is hopefully just
to get get us all thinking about what
might be possible so starting with crowd
workers I'm going to focus on a couple
of tied together elements on credentials
in education because when we when you
try to get a job today you probably say
things like hey
I graduated from Stanford or I work for
Google and these actually carry quite a
lot of meaning if you look at
crowdsourcing at the same time today
this is oDesk people trying to signal
their expertise it's it looks like
Netflix and eBay does this collapse
toward high ratings people signaling
their their their their abilities like
they're on Craigslist
so saying typing in all-caps saying my
official job title is being a web
rockstar and I just refuse to believe
that the future of of crab work is going
to be saying that I have 4.2 stars out
of 5 as a composer so we can start to
pitch toward some cement goals here yeah
because that's actually collapsing first
of all everyone has 4.2 stars out of 5
and I think that's a problem I think
it's one that we could solve technically
but it's also not clear that it has the
right dimensions of variants captured in
it I think you could at the end of the
day try to come up with a single number
and me and maybe you could for
composition in particular but it's not
clear that it's the same number that you
want to be comparing people who are
programmers it seems like one potential
feature is that
and sure I think that if we do nothing
that's likely what's going to happen is
that micro micro tasks will continue to
be micro tasks and we'll never really
see a growth or we will see several
Board of tries to grow out of that
until someone really gets it I think
that if we do this right the Mechanical
Turk in
current instantiation weather will get
replaced by something far better you
know either Amazon does it or we do it
you know so yeah yes slightly different
take on the switches go ahead and do
this it'll probably get ignored anyway
so there were times maybe I want to hire
a programmer and I care let you up 4.5
billions of 3.5 I care but I also need a
lot more details about the volume
dimensionality of it's absent since
we're going to blow past this anyway
let's gets where the interesting stuff
is where is the action which becomes
like GPA and graduate school application
sort it's hardly what do you make the
decisions people get star ratings and I
would claim that I think and I think
oDesk would also claim that there's a
lot more to be done
so I pitched an alternative view here
which is I think it would be possible to
create these kinds of reputation
mechanisms that should be as
straightforward to deploy and interpret
as what we have today in terms of
degrees and affiliations I think there
are ways that we can think about how to
scale that out to many more individuals
than we have today so this would be the
first kind of specific yet out there
kind of millennial goal that I think we
might think about working toward another
tie to it is education because if you
want to get credentialing you need to
think about education and the especially
in the last couple years you've seen the
internet really playing a big role in
self driven learning and crime because
that has the opportunity to empower this
process so this person is actually
creating their first sort of Arduino
prototype and so what I'd love to think
about is ways in which we can help this
person go from their first hello world
program
all the way out to becoming an expert
and actually support that at the level
of the kind of work that they want to do
so to throw something out there that's
probably a little more strongly worded
than I would actually try to pursue
quick crowd work actually become
equivalent to or at least a core part of
Education so you think about this the
job that this person wants to do
involves learning C so she turns to an
online course to do that and and the
course is able to use some simple actual
work as assignments for the course if
they're fulfilling learning goals as she
completes the course she can use the
credentials from that course to actually
take on more new or more interesting
work so I think that we can actually tie
these things a lot closer together so
that would be a second kind of goal that
I that we would be able to push toward
moving to work so from workers to work
hierarchy is a really interesting one
because we could actually pitch
something that is clearly not true right
now which is crowd work being as
well-managed as the best managers and I
read Nicky Couture puts this so I'm
going to to crib from here him here
saying that this guy is a pretty good
manager his name is Tim Cook he's the
CEO of Apple and he got paid a lot last
year you know he doesn't matter thinks
for Apple he's streamlining their supply
chain he's improving their workflow he's
thinking about products and we could
again ask you know could a crowd worker
actually bring that much value to an
enterprise and maybe it's not a single
worker maybe actually you have this
distributed leadership model where some
folks are good at at different things
like providing feedback providing
directions supply chains reward
sanctions if we pull everyone together
maybe we could actually create a
self-managed enterprise in an
interesting sense and we can look at
successful examples like online
communities like Wikipedia open source
software that might start to provide
some models for this kind of thing so
hierarchy also I think touches on
workflow and as I sort of started
- intimate the the workflows in
crowdsourcing right now look a lot like
this very endeavor n she ated single
track or a single stage and you know as
researchers we've started to create
these kinds of things this is Nikki
Couture's crowd weaver that starts to
get a bit more complicated and to be
honest as researchers in this area we
get really excited about this kind of
thing until you look at what real
workflows look like this is a TV station
that's and has a workflow for producing
programming so a new show and their work
looks like this yes could you produce a
TV show with less than this yeah
possibly I think it would certainly be
more than a single stage you know put a
task out on on oDesk say make a TV show
right so I think at some level there's
there's going to be a connection between
them so I think how complex it is is an
open question but certainly we should
think about ones that have girls that
are at least this complex things that
are as high quality maybe faster more
dynamic than the kinds of workflows you
and I use today and in order to get
towards this I think this is where again
we can think about how computing might
play in in terms of ways of creating
sort of shared libraries design patterns
saying that well you if you want to
actually get this kind of result this
kind of approach tends to work and here
now we can turn back to the to the
management literature to see where these
things come from procedure actually not
like computer procedures they're open
procedure where the people ourselves
repair somebody goes on vacation
but the person designing the machine
that procedure doesn't even know about
that but somebody covers for somebody
else and so the procedures yeah so
so this is where crowdsourcing right
mountains to fall over to be honest is
we you know these these workflows that
that we've created so far have strong
assumptions in them and when there's
some assumptions start breaking down
then they completely fall over but I
think when you start to get at this kind
of scale you need these I mean someone
might call it a self-healing system
right but I think in an organization you
have someone covering for another person
I would say maybe not I mean there's
they're interesting models right one one
could say that like one model of cobbler
would be to say that each piece in this
could in theory be replaceable with
someone else who does this thing just as
well so if I'm gonna go on vacation
another crowd worker might come in who's
just as good at audio programming that
kind of thing so in some ways we could
actually keep the the situation flowing
even more smoothly but we'll probably
fail a lot in order to get there so I'll
pitch one other thing about platforms
here and I think the platforms are a
really interesting opportunity for us to
get involved
so far we've largely said yes Mechanical
Turk is out there or oDesk is out there
and we're going to just figure out how
to how to involve it in our own
endeavors but I think if you if you
pitch forward you might be able to to
look toward a future where crap
platforms would either coexist with or
even in a strong version replace for
firms so something where you could
create a flash startup that would only
exist for an afternoon or a team of
expert crowd workers who consult for
thousands of jobs over a period of years
I think this is a kind of situation that
we might be able to start aiming for and
saying what would it
to get there and this is where and the
reason I think this is important is this
is why I pitched my my week war fee and
hypothesis of of crowdsourcing which is
that the platform's have a really strong
influence on the kind of work that
actually gets done there I would claim
that given how Mechanical Turk was
designed is somewhat inevitable that it
was going to to lean toward small tasks
low pay people not being able to talk to
each other
but if you create a different platform
you'll get a different kind of outcome
and I think that we can create these
kinds of platforms to create new kinds
of work so and furthermore there are
some of these challenges that rarely can
be solved at the platform level if we
want to for example say if you do good
work
if you're contributing well we promise
that in expectation you'll make the
amount the amount of money that you want
to this is something that really only
the platform can start to mediate and
likewise making people feel comfortable
spending a fair amount of time there in
terms of long term employment you know
right now on oDesk year you're sort of
listing from job to job which doesn't
feel very comfortable I would claim for
many people who want to feel a little
bit more solid in their employment
status and this is already happening if
you look at UC Berkeley they they spun
out mobile works which is grew out of
crowdsourcing research I think we really
can influence and build these platforms
and have a lot of impacts so this is a
super brief overview I think some of the
interesting opportunities that are out
there for us in crowdsourcing work
moving forward in terms of the workers
the works the computation and I say
brief because we covered about a third
or a quarter of the kinds of things that
are discussed in in the paper that we
wrote about this which I believe was the
longest CSE w paper in history now that
they went to a continuous length format
and there are many many opportunities so
we're missing things here and I would
encourage you to tell me what we're
missing because we're all going to
benefit from that and also to think
about how you
can contribute because you whatever you
bring to the table whether you have
expertise in qualitative work system
engineering social psychology there are
things that you can help us do so before
I move on I'll just sort of close out
this part of what I see well I'd like to
see crowdsourcing research start to move
with I've been drawing back to this
question of how do we create a positive
social outcome for crowdsourcing and I
think we do that by starting to to
create the platforms the workers the
computational structures that allow you
to feel comfortable and have a growth
potential in this kind of system rather
than just thinking about how to optimize
given the strata we already have yeah
interesting this is part two of politics
or democracy when you vote for example
and there's there's a bit of a model
here that's implicit in what I've been
talking about where the technology is
taking a strong hand that I think many
democracies would would chafe at a bit
you know I think we taste enough that
you know having a having the Supreme
Court decide an election for us now
having an algorithm say actually you
should go over here and vote for this
guy seems perhaps less than ideal but
thinking about ways to actually get
people to have conversations to come to
consensus --is you know there's a lot of
work about getting local local groups to
have discussions together if everyone
believes in the system then I think you
could do it crowd work in a sense
because it's paid has an element of
coercion that is not really or lightly
incentivization that that's not present
in democracies yeah
the problems with things like keys work
and work at home and contract it's a
requirement
there are also based on the assumption
that employers are the next my process
results may be programming isn't one of
many jobs even very happy is a
relatively small term in terms of
profits and that this kind of platform
is going to substance cut off the bility
of governments in general very good wage
so minimal hourly wage I think that so
the with the research hat on I think we
need to fix that before regulation needs
to step in to do it because once
regulation steps in we we may not make
the right decisions we may be more
reactionary than thoughtful so my my
bowl here would be to say well if that's
the concern
how do we actually design the system the
platform the the socio technical
environment to avoid that problem well
at the end of the day I think you know
Amazon for example cares more about the
requesters than they do about the
workers however without the workers they
have no requesters anyway so I think
that you know who's at the end of the
day you have a lot of businesses and
businesses have bottom lines that depend
on on the people who are paying them but
maybe this is why research is important
in this space is that we can stake out
in to get into directions that may not
be driven by profits immediately but
that would in the long term
help profits mister thought
I think the more obligations that you
have two workers depends on your model
of what role crowd work plays in their
life which laughing here's the opening
question is really interesting if your
model of Mechanical Turk is somebody
gets their health care from something
that they do outside of Mechanical Turk
yep and Turk is basically a different
way of wasting time besides watching
sports then you know if you get some
spending money out of it great but on
the other hand if you're expecting your
shirt worth two carriers into retirement
and your medical treatment and I think
we should be ambitious and think about
what we want someone to be able to spend
all their time doing this you know if
you view today's contractors people who
create their own consulting firms as the
leading edge of this what it would take
between here and there to get you know
an order of magnitude more individuals
participating in that it's sort of for
me at least a motivating question if not
an answer I have quite yet there's room
in this for other kinds of organizations
that are using it better and I could
overlay on top of this infrastructure
and shops that hire contractors to other
companies but still pay those
contractors benefits even though the
contractors have paid an hourly wage
we've done the short term so as you can
imagine this enabling something similar
right and I think many consulting
agencies do this right they'll provide
the healthcare and your sentence of
employment and then it becomes the rule
of the organization to make sure there's
enough work to do so interesting models
everywhere
yeah that's all about quality control
actually so I should my bet that's not
my experience imagine I'd talk there's a
kind of redundancies on making some
mission of the task actually for example
you can make a mistake on one some work
and the other guys should be involved to
make a correction so my question my
question is there's a lot overhead for
ending redundancies of tasks and to make
a collocation
and another question is kind of
confidentiality and modularity of the
workers maybe some kind of a reputation
can solve the problem what stated we I
think we have to use them Carlos
so what was the question the second
question just a comment second question
is kind of an elaborate tape of it
oh very well curse yes yeah also some
kind of potential intercept a sketchy
confidentiality of the task yeah from
the present some of the perspective of
the workers so they can't know who what
they're looking at
yeah so from there okay from there
you've got some company's point of view
so they use some Carla well Chris then
yes their information can be make to
those crops sure so I think you know you
seek what companies are doing now is
actually creating crowds within their
organization they're paying contract
workers or their large scale contract
outlets and then have everyone sign an
NDA which is an interesting model and I
think one that the Challenger pointing
out is going to become even even more
present you know if you have a model
where even a start-up can actually reach
out to you know a designer for a few
hours for some feedback or a front-end
engineer for help debugging something
you're going to have a lot of
high-throughput confidentiality breaches
basically and thinking about how people
actually treat each other and and the
respect for some always changing
organization is hard but yes and
redundancy I would back your original
question I think that you know why do we
have the redundancy it's because we
maybe don't trust everyone or maybe what
you know the good news about redundancy
is you want a lot of opinions the bad
reason is because you don't trust any
single person and I'm in favor of the
first one I think the second one I'd
rather pay someone five times as much
and then do good work rather than need
to pay someone one-fifth as much and get
five of them so
four-bit to opportunities in social
computing and I say this because I think
that that crowdsourcing really only gets
us so far this is going to be a section
on friend sourcing in particular and why
friend source well
crowdsourcing gets us pretty far that it
can and in particular it helps with
things that have massive scale you know
trying to label every image on the web
or identify good links or identify every
Buffy the Vampire Slayer episode ever
and yet it struggles when only a few
people are qualified so wikipedia has
something it's either 1/100 of a percent
or 1/10 of a percent of all its views
become edits and if you only have 1000
into 10,000 views total you're really
going to struggle so you get anything to
happen just as a sort of facetious
example here we can you know ask Yahoo
Answers what to get my friend further
for their birthday and let's facetiously
actually do so and get no responses say
yeah who happens to be there and so in
particularly a large number of
applications where things need to know
about the individual maybe about you or
about others who would be using it
things like QA routing news feeds my
sixth sense which is trying to take a
newsfeed and personalize it to your own
tastes and crowds just really can't help
you very much from there but there is a
set of people who can I am particularly
point to your friends your family your
colleagues it's a much smaller set of
people but if we could actually get them
to participate at a higher rate then we
might still actually be able to succeed
and this is the idea behind friend
sourcing that I'd like to pitch to be
specific I think that one thing we might
aim for is given a person to get a sort
of weighted term vector of things that
describe them so given that we know
about Greg Smith what can we say about
him and particularly without asking him
to sit there and tag himself the entire
time I first jaunt into this space was
something called collab II
which we're actually deployed in the
early days of Facebook applications it
basically works out like a game of
social family feud where what you would
do is give him a tag cloud of what Kurt
here's other friends have said about
them that's obscured we try to dress
what others have said about Kurt here I
guessed Georgia Tech ten people have
guessed that so I get a certain number
of points we can continue to go all the
way down on this list until maybe I
would get something like eventually I'll
guess is Twitter handle resurgence that
no one else's guests and then something
new gets added to the tag cloud and you
can play this game and in fact as we do
so it'll scroll down here to the left we
identified Becky winter who's a faculty
member at Georgia Tech and those Curt
far better than I do so when a lot of
people do this you get tagged cards that
look something like this this is
actually something like one fifth of my
own tagcloud
it's a spec and is interesting because
people from a lot of different walks of
my life have actually shared information
about me and so it's it's non monolithic
in the sense that it knows a lot of
different perspectives about me and I
just want to point out that Columbia is
one way to do this I'm gonna point out
some things that I think didn't work so
well one is do you want to actually
encourage people to go after popular
information when we tried it the other
way in fact rewarding giving more points
the fewer other people who had said it
provided that at least one other person
had turned out there was no agreement no
points and in fact when you reward the
common information when people aim for
the common stuff they often miss and
that's when you really learn something
likewise bootstrapping untied users were
you when you're walking and start this
game there's an empty tag cloud
originally we started just by
effectively this is before unification
but it was effectively game game options
here extra points if you're the first
person no one did this turned out that
we could sort of put it on the door is
now calling benevolent deception and
basically scrape a few tags off your
profile put them into the into this tag
cloud for the first person get them to
try to match that that type cloud by
attributing it to someone else who they
don't know
once they've done so we remove the
automatically generated tags and the
other ones that someone actually left
there so there's a lot that can be done
here in fact just as we collected
something like 30,000 tags on 4,000
individuals actually a relatively
smaller number of taggers only about 800
of them participated but as I'll get to
that this might actually be a design
opportunity moving forward with it we
ran some evaluation that I won't go into
too much depth on looking at whether
these tags are accurate whether they can
be found elsewhere and we thought was
that these tags that were the most
popular actually were quite could be
found say on Facebook or Google things
like MIT where I did grad school but the
things that we're sort of in the torso
of this or in the longer tail we're both
accurate and not available anywhere else
on the web which means that we can do
all sorts of interesting things
here for example we might allow you to
actually explore your social network
based on what your friends have said
about each other or compare people who
are tagged with Georgia tag to people
who are jacked tagged with Washington
and again here we are actually relying
not a million individuals to tag
themselves but to get the social Matt
network to tag each other
and here's why this is super super
useful we can start to build
applications like this this was as sort
of an early precursor of aardvark in a
sense where I can say where can I find
lunch near the Palo Alto Research Center
and folks who get tagged with both of
them I'm sorry with Park tend to show up
these individuals didn't tag themselves
as Park in fact there may never have
even played collab eyo but we're able to
do this kind of question routing relying
on here just so that 800 individuals who
ended up being really active
contributors to the to the platform and
so this is useful for across the network
but we can also again turn back to some
of these personalized applications like
here
scraping 30,000 items in an RSS feed
over the course of a day this is just
sort of we will hear some random ones
x-files cars the PTR and then we can
start to just personalize these by using
cosine distance on the tag clouds this
is again my tag cloud and what you start
to see is a much more relevant feed
things about PhD
in HCI information schools nerd culture
this is a friend who's a doctor and a
tenor in New York again a different set
of feed items and a third one who's a
friend who's a rock musician basically
and and you again start to see content
that's relevant to that so that's a
first attack here but we might be able
to actually take advantage of existing
social interactions instead of creating
new ones I think this is an interesting
perspective because now instead of
thinking about well okay how do we
actually encourage people to install
some application get things to happen
can we ride on what's already happening
and I'll pitch one at you again today
which is about content sharing this is
something you probably have happened to
you all the time hey I saw this this is
actually relevant to something that
you're doing and it actually does tend
to be fairly relevant unless it's a
coming from your grandma who's passing
you something from you know three weeks
ago and we have to cut the question so
who should we be enabling here hmm when
option ability to say well the shares
are people who are seeking out a lot of
content and in that case we should
actually be going after people who are
these information brokers and the people
on our RSS feeds or Twitter another
hypothesis might be that they're
actually especially social individuals
so we want to identify people who are
say central to a networker of high
degree and we can start to separate
between these hypothesis we I bought the
C's we ran a survey on Mechanical Turk
with a large number of about 30
questions all on a scale sorry for
scales are like style questions and what
we're trying to measure is the interest
in eventually sharing content so this is
an example question off that scale I
tell often tell people I know about my
favorite websites to follow and we've
used it to try to predict things I'd say
we used the rest of them to try to
predict their sharing interest one was
the seeking measure things like I often
seek out entertaining posts on the
internet and then to nisshin's of
sociality drawing on the co Ellison and
their friends work on social capital
there are two types one is
bridging social capital this is roughly
roughly the Bowling Alone kind of social
capital where you're trying to
understand someone's interest in meeting
new people investment in their community
or bonding social capital having a small
number of friends who you really retain
tight relationships with and what we
started to see was that the seeking
measures actually correlated much more
strongly with the sharing than similar
and sociality which surprised me to be
honest
and in fact adding the social capital
measures to this regression only
explained an additional 3% of variance
so on from 0.53 2.5 6 so we actually
have some fairly strong evidence that
the shares that we can enable are really
those who are seeking out a lot of
content and maybe some mixed results
here that being interested in talking in
in meeting people in general it's still
somewhat predictive but having a few
close friends really doesn't predict
someone's interest in sharing so maybe
we can start to empower those heavy
information consumers to actually create
the same kind of content and we can do
that by going where they live say in
their RSS feed errs RSS readers excuse
me and making this easier to happen to
have happen so rather than trying to get
everyone on Facebook to tag each other
let's actually aim at those few people
who are extremely active and make it
easier for them to share let's lower
that activation barrier and try to
address some of the inhibitions so the
recommendations just get inserted in
line Google Reader if you're familiar
with it looks just like this we've added
this this particular addition so that
when you actually are reading an item
all you need to do is say we recommend
people who might be interested and we
say ok you click on that and then say
now or later and then that just sends an
email saying this person thought you
might be interested in it so it's
directed content sharing rather than
sort of broadcast like on Twitter and by
doing so we can start to build these
matters again so we see that two people
share share items with Rob and we can
just combine those documents to build up
a profile of what Rob might be
interested in and when we see a new item
we can pull out this very basic bag of
words representation do some cosine
distance and identify the individual
who's most likely to be interested in
that kind of in that kind of article a
few other things we try to address some
of these inhibitions have this person
received a lot of information already
today how much are we sending them or
did they already see it did someone else
send it to them or am i overrun in their
inbox can I sit can I should I send it
now or just say I'll send everything all
at once maybe once a week something that
was a sort of surprisingly effective to
us was the email equivalent of a like
button the ability for someone to just
click one button and say thanks for
sharing this and in the system he would
respond with a very simple email 30% of
what got sent through the system
generated effects which is roughly by
hour by hour counts equivalent to the
number of items on Facebook that get at
least one like but keep in mind here
that rather than having your entire
social network possibly giving likes
this was from a single individual who is
probably receiving the content yes to
address the recommendations accidental
disclosure was interesting so you
imagine that Iraq's out you know
essentially shared with me some item
relevant to say cancer for one reason or
another and if you're then browsing
Google Reader and you see an article
about cancer and I get recommended for
it there's all sorts of interesting
questions there I think that's that's
the one that I would pick off first but
you have the genteel like mute is also a
good
let's to silently mute themselves from
the recommendations for a person
so let's say I'm sending you bad stuff
all you need to do is go into the system
and say stop recommending me for Terry
and then I would no longer appear if if
if you then still wanted to manually
send me something we course couldn't
stop you but I think there is sort of
this we're trying to make it quietly
possible to decline or gin a genteel way
I think we don't have a great answer
there but people who actually have good
taste have said you know if jeff has
great taste for Terry you can just say
yeah me too I went to that one to give
it yeah it's maybe something he isn't
higher than me but a lot of times I
don't use the sender's from this service
link and I just copy the link and see
anything heals just at the plate because
kind of I'll make the fact that their
times is tracking or communicating with
whoever is so under and has you explored
these various channels 50 40 years
things and you said we can get all this
information there that that sort of runs
into other issues with why people are
using this some of these thoughts that
came out of the group lens stuff about
do you want federated recommendation
engines like it should I be able to keep
private all of the knowledge that I've
that I'm sharing in a sense about my
friends or is this something where we
actually do do better by sharing yeah me
and you are ELLs in there the comebacker
users of the email
I know is that good I'm not sure you
know there's some breach of privacy
there but at the perspective of running
a user study we really wanted to know so
yes we proxied the urls so and that's
from when last time here to data and I
think there's a lot of opportunities
here and I think actually that this
isn't I am sort of preaching to the
choir to the extent that I think all of
my other colleagues in this group
already get this but I'd like to pitch
again one perspective here which is why
why is it that crowd data might be
actually opening up avenues for design
of interactive systems that we might not
have seen before
and one reason that might be is thinking
about long tail design traditionally
we've thought about this sort of 80/20
we're trying to get trying to cover as
much as we can and make everything else
possible but not easy you could also
think about saying well actually let's
build a ship and in that ship will
actually let via like the denizens of it
organize it in such a way that it
becomes useful for them and I'll give
you one example here on the web where
we've manually created answers for a
small number of things answers or 1
boxes if your Google respond to queries
like like this not just with results but
also with simply that's specifically
designed and this is really powerful
because you know you you could have
movies dates stocks but ultimately and
I'm sorry and these are good because we
know that they're they're people they're
actually removing the clicks from the
results pages meaning people are finding
what they're looking for and that once
they figure out that one of these exists
people repeatedly trigger these things
but they really only exist for a small
number of queries the answers are high
cost you have to create them high
maintenance you have to make sure they
don't break and really search is
dominated by uncommon things in fact
you take a six-month log of queries only
50% of those queries are unique they
only appear once once which is
incredible when you think about it given
the number of times people are searching
for Facebook so you have a lot of things
that look like this molasses substitutes
increasing the volume on Windows XP does
almost stitches
what's the temperature of a dog what we
started doing was creating tail answers
which given that kind of a query not
only returns the results but actually
again starts to think about what it
would take to design for a huge number
of somewhat popular responses I mean
somewhat popular in the following way
weather movies clearly happening all the
time asking where a car is going to be
in several years probably not very
popular and maybe not worth creating a
specific result for but there's this
perhaps torso you might call it up the
curve well I think there's a large
number of individuals who'd be
interested but the volume is so large
that you can't actually design for every
single one of them so they're also
scenarios with there's probably not only
structured information schemas yet
unlike weather or movies and we don't
want to actually dedicate teams to them
so we create these tale answers across
whatever empirically send what popular
queries things like how many calories on
our green apple what's the mileage
reimbursement for the IRS how do you
turn up volume on Windows XP what
temperature do you fry fish at yes
basically its superior in the evaluation
that we did but you can also I will
briefly mention you can use this kind of
technique to create better snippets so
I'm not sure they're really in
contention so there are some typos here
I want to point out these aren't perfect
which is an interesting thing that
happens when you allow sort of crowds to
collectively influence the internals of
the system so now Microsoft in this case
or Bing says here's our collectively
here's what boom things
the answer is and it has a typo in it
sort of an interesting kind of situation
to be in I want to briefly just give you
a sense of how this is possible and what
I want to hopefully take away from this
is that data is powerful but it's also
extremely noisy and just like in in
machine learning features feature
construction is often 90% of the game
here I think thinking about what the
model is and what we need to filter out
becomes just as important we start with
answer candidates which is basically
every set of queries that leads to a
click on a single URL so we we can
observe for a subset of individuals who
have installed a browser toolbar
effectively their entire browsing path
because this is work time in
collaboration with Microsoft and they
and they can do that so notice that all
of these queries lead to a click-through
from the results of a particular URL and
we have a lot of these things so you
know lots of other queries might lead
through to a click through on another
URL it's probably about the area code
for one oh and now we have this filter
and filtering is interesting one thing
we want to do is get rid of things like
this a lot of people who search for
radio click on Pandora comm that's not
the kind of thing you actually want to
provide an answer for you actually want
some sort of navigational result there
so what we start doing is trying to
identify searches that have some sort of
fact-finding nature so we start looking
for navigation behavior query behavior
answer type and is a combination of
statistics and and heuristics to be
honest so we start looking at the
destination probability what is what we
call it basically the probability that
you click through to from a result and
end your session so here we have some
notion that you're probably happy with
what you found here you went on and and
we're looking for something else or you
hit the back button so in this case very
easy to calculate you know 50% of the
time people who clicked through to this
URL stopped there and what we can start
to do
is center of anything that has a little
probability that searchers are going to
end I'm sorry there are things that have
high probability that committing this
backwards filter out things where it's
likely that once you get there you're
going to move on or go back so we want
to find things where people stop and
this gonna allow us to focus on queries
where there's really a solved
information need but that doesn't give
us enough because we have quest we have
queries like this design of the stitches
72 area code and we don't know exactly
what answers are trying to go after and
you know do we want to know how long the
dissolvable stitches last what they're
made out of what the brand name is so
here is where I return to is sort of a
filtering heuristic and we we take
advantage of the fact that a small
number of searchers actually use
question words or fully specified
searches
how long do dissolvable stitches last
where is the 732 area code and if we get
almost nothing in terms of that kind of
a query we don't know what we're going
to be able to say so we simply filter it
out we care more about precision here
than recall and finally there are
different kinds of answers right
something where I can answer with a
short phrase something where you might
get a list so like here's how to change
your password of a remote desktop or
actually summary synthesis synthesis of
things so what is the impact of budget
cuts on teachers was a somewhat popular
query in our data set
not something we can easily answer with
a single sentence and in fact you would
probably need to go read a bunch in
order to figure that out I'm just going
to focus for now with what we do on the
short queries which is starting to
extract the answer from the page so we
now have these answer candidates with
factual responses succinct responses but
we don't know what they are you know all
we have is a query in a page so now we
actually this is where I perhaps run
around with a hammer that I have too
often we actually do turn to
crowdsourcing we say we can't we can't
do this automatically so we're going to
ask folks for help we're going to show
them the page the queries and say please
extract what you need in order to answer
this or to show to someone else who
asked would have asked this question now
colon control was brought up when we
when we
do this this is kind of the equivalent
of what we get
I'm obscuring the actual text just the
point is that it's really long but what
we can start to do is develop quality
control techniques here to say this kind
of in this example we know that this
thing needs to show up and this thing I
better not be there and when we start
doing that we actually get a slightly
better response which is you know closer
to like a sentence or two there isn't
I'm not showing actual textures because
it ends up being incredibly distracting
it's about really interesting things oh
yeah you know the there they're entering
their Conclave next week and yeah so we
can produce these kinds of results you
know given a whole bunch of search
trails we can produce about 20,000
answer candidates medium one triggered
actually only once a day in our data set
it's about you know three hundred fifty
times a year and cost about forty four
cents to create each answer with the
with the crowd sourcing technique that
we use so just briefly I'm gonna point
out that you know when you hand coded
these it was about 85% correct
as you saw there were some things that
had a typo of some sort and others were
the title the thing that they said they
were trying to solve actually did not
match the the content of what they what
was copy pasted out and when manipulate
this is going to Jews question when we
manipulate the presence of answers and
the rank and quality of the search
results what we find is that these tale
answers actually impact these ratings
about half as much as ranking does some
in some sense because we're actually
ranking at in effect at the top a really
good answer
but it does clearly compensate for
having really trash in the rest of your
search results yeah you could use
crowdsourcing to create these tale
results yes so they're real people
responding no no not in real time we
okay you're then presuming that this is
gonna be a useful result because
someone's going to come along later
that's what asked that same question
that's right you said that over 50
percent of them only else can ask once
so there's this
not the kids percent that never get
asked to continue right we're focusing
on movies that show maybe twice once a
day so our training data was over
several months so we had enough enough
data to actually understand more or less
how common this kind of query would be
so yes we're going to lag interest you
can think of some really interesting
applications where we notice oh my gosh
this thing is really spiking we need to
handcraft a search result very quickly
and then you might go off to the crowd
have it be it be edited and then put
that in front of users but here we're
doing it more or less offline for things
that are sort of common somewhat common
needs so yeah we have some interesting
challenges the crowd has a lot of
editorial control you know you can get
this kind of thing happening where you
know we are we want to write about the
sea of China but the but the crowd
decides that we should be actually
writing about the Sea of Japan and also
some ethical issues where we're now
again cannibalizing pages from the
original page Google does this all the
time
is this something we actually want to
push forward and just as Jim is pointing
out we could use these some kind of
techniques to go from the snippet that
looks like this whereas sniffing is the
black text something that's actually for
example authored a little bit more
nicely given the queries that we know
are happening we're producing
domain-specific answers saying well we
know that there's an entire set of
answers here which aren't being covered
people searching for how to concatenate
strings in PHP or produce that across
multiple languages so that you could say
well what's the PHP a J a reg oh and
look like in Python or lo the other
direction know what is pythons slicing
syntax look like in PHP and I plays with
just a few fresh ideas over the next two
minutes or so and just to give you a
sense of the kinds of opportunities I
see these are a few things where I want
to give shoutouts to the rotation
students who are working with me for the
last nine weeks so these things are
extremely fresh doing things like mining
programming patterns off the web for
example identifying patterns that real
programmers use in real Ruby code and
then giving you the ability
say actually here's some other examples
of how it's done you could think about
Auto completing you could think about
providing metadata or stronger compile
time support for that kind of thing
thinking about doing sensing for for
clouds locally if we were to actually
just hold up a phone or a laptop in this
room what can we learn about what people
were doing just by by listening to Wi-Fi
traffic so here you might be able to say
notice that everyone in this lecture is
just actually looking at Gizmodo comm
well that people are actually fairly
statically sitting here rather than say
a coffee shop where they're coming in
and out all the time so the previous
project was done by Ethan this one is by
John and we'll here's Joe and Justin who
were thinking about massive
participatory fiction writing if Neil
remain wanted to actually write a short
story and have people contribute small
parts of it like leaving side stories
open would that be possible
okay starting collective action by
Justin thinking about things like peer
office hours which we've actually
deployed in CS 107 this quarter sort of
a Kickstarter kind of model where I'll
be rid of 20 other people also sign up
but here for volunteer efforts something
like I'll show up to these office hours
if there are other people who are also
going to show up or I'll sure I'll join
this flash mob but only if other if 20
other people do it too so that's just a
a few pokes into the kinds of directions
I'd love to push in and some of the
directions i've pushed in in the past
and i would love to chat more but in the
meantime i think you guys have a friday
afternoon to get back - thanks
yes I seem to be sitting with the old
folks here the retirees what would be
one of the things that I worry about in
life in general I'm gonna hear a lot of
philosophy from you in the next 20
seconds about this kind of busy
low-level stuff from Mechanical Turk
versus where God thinks about a problem
for 30 years and has imagined a spectrum
where you've got yet so and my question
to you is with what you're endeavoring
to do how far along that spectrum can
you push crowd with which relation on
that that's a great question I think
that one interesting response you might
have is let's say you have this 50 year
goal well but but but obviously the
stuff that society really respects are
those yeah the Nobel prize-winning work
in Barcelona right this this church that
go D yes create a designed and never
live to see the completion of in fact
it's still not done in a sense you have
this vision that was articulated at the
beginning and you have individuals who
are continuing to realize it so I think
that's a really interesting question of
having ideas that outlive perhaps even a
single individual or or short period I
you could flip it around to another
question which would be if I have
something that's going to take me 50
years to complete how could I actually
engage with others to help me complete
it either far better in 50 years or
possibly shorter in a shorter period of
time but yes the the the into the little
tiny tasks I think might not map well
hunt to that I'm struck by the
difference
a point of view that you get to in
crowdsourcing we start from something
like Mechanical Turk anointment as
opposed to notion bank for increased
production whenever you come in here
that matter examples would really like
pure production the difference is sorted
the amount of control or poverty lack of
control powerlessness you happen to one
situation versus the initiative and
ability to see the larger parts and how
you fit yeah there are there's other
differences they just don't occur to me
it's a it's a really interesting if you
take a scale like you see the hole that
you're contributing to know you have
power I'm not sure that there's a strict
delineation between paid crowd work and
unpaid pure production in this sense you
know one of the the legitimate
peripheral participation kinds of things
that you see on Wikipedia
in fact my Krieger did this kind of
stuff with Scott was identifying that
people come in and all they start doing
is reverting bad edits and this is how
people get started on Wikipedia and I
don't claim that that's right roughly
isomorphic to doing little micro tasks
but it's crowdsourcing it I I hesitate
to try and come up with a concise
definition of crowdsourcing my my rough
one is asking a large set of people for
help with something which is not very
precise but is been use for so far
because it adapts to whatever I mean at
the moment I think that really the this
may end up being a difference in some
sense of intrinsic and extrinsic
motivators where you know with something
like Wikipedia or the polymath project
where people were all contributing to a
huge math proof you have people who are
there because they want to be and I
think if you start to layer requirements
and saying you must do it this way it
might be a little abrasive I mean this
does happen but you know Jimmy rails
does
say Wikipedia's going to do this he's
the benevolent benevolent dictator model
but I think at the end of the day you're
you're there because you want to know
because I'm paying you
you